I know it sounds irrational but there's
like almost like two voices in my head
there's one that's like trying to like
create like self-preservation and
another one that's like just a little
bit louder that's like we can win
anything we want so one guy is like dude
don't do that you're going to embarrass
us please we don't know what we're doing
but the other voice was like that
let's do this we'll figure it out on the
Fly it'll be a real Challenge and like
let's get uncomfortable yeah and then I
and then and then when I text you and
you like oh that's a claimed many Ultra
Runners all I heard was you're not tough
enough for that and I oh that's what you
heard yes that's not what I was saying I
know I knew what you meant I knew you
had the best intentions but I used that
as like motivation I was like I signed
up as soon as I got that text from you I
was like I'm in I'm doing it and
immediately I was like I'm winning